und wenn ihr das video sehen was geht
im norden sind wir laufen hier gerade
durch hamburg das eine tolle sache und
ich bin jetzt herangekommen
ich nehme euch jetzt mal so ein bisschen
was von der taube getötet urlaub machen
wir suchen ja etwas zu fressen unterwegs
ist alles ja wenn ich mittlerweile auch
schon jetzt schon wieder so viel
eingekauft hier eine badehose und dann
sehen wir uns gleich alles längst
erwachsen grill beim grill denken gibt
es öfters dreimal alter mann bei allen
dreien gut die currywurst da ist heftig
heftigkeit also unbedingt dahin gehend
ritus essen und dann war ich auch dass
man bei starbucks cafe per email salome
flames countryman groß geholt ganz groß
das hat mir das ganz lester bangs
vernichten
es ist so von allen fing alles halt ohne
kaffee ist es kalt und das ist ein
sommertag
jetzt gehen wir die europa passage und
danach noch mal das nächste krise zu
gerade in der europa passage auf einem
es kostet ich habe außerdem zwei euro
reingeschmissen zehn minuten lang sind
noch achteinhalb von denen dazu offen
bringen und es lohnt sich gar nicht also
ich jetzt keine kasse macht nicht ganz
konkreter wir sind in der europa passage
in der überzahl stasi-akten und
und das ist sehr sehr cool und gleich
dass ich mit handy
es gab von kronen
das hat man aus nach vorne sehen
ein auto geklaut das wieder befestigt er
steht oft sehr unauffällig auf ihrem
handy laden weg man nicht schon dass
viel auf einmal durch wir sehen was
hingegen mit taschenlampen
wir sind jetzt gerade und warf sein
wollen ja du kannst doch nicht essen
gerade noch
spaniens
zurück zum kinderschutz vor massa salat
gegessen weil beim alex
im auto sind nicht mehr ein abend burg
das ist übrigens für den halt der ist
total europa belegt berichtet anke
englisch
wir fahren jetzt gerade den dammer kino
kino genau
wir fahren jetzt viel wie ein thema des
internets wir gucken jetzt ihrer des
untergangs es ist immens heißt es ist
wirklich irgendwie ich würde sagen jetzt
locker noch 26 grad draußen obwohl es
schon 19 uhr verbissen gekämpft und wir
fahren da jetzt hin zum kinostart als im
film ich melde seiner mitschüler sind
und nicht mehr so viel
wunderschöne stadt junge mädchen weil
sie nicht ist schön hier nicht weiter
aus wenn ihr dann hier von hamburgs 19
19 limburg
was muss passieren
unsere sind
herzlich willkommen zum nächsten tag
wieder nicht nur der ausgleich
hierzu bank und dann hat vielleicht
wieder nach hause mache aber
wahrscheinlich weil ich kein bock auf
unter drei stunden
100.000 kamera direkt und für mich auch
was im auto ich noch mal gucken auf
jeden fall ist auf jeden fall stelle ich
habe mich aber ich werde auf jeden fall
nächsten wochen mal hinfahren und dann
hätte ich mir mehr 5
wenn ihr hamburg seite geht auf jeden
fall wenn wir viel und gut essen geht in
schmalegg wenn ihr einfach schneller
machen wollt geht zum nulltarif
minute stoppen wollte europas weil das
alles was uns aufhalten die tore gut
führen
das sage ich wollte euch gleich mit der
inflation und nicht kriegt das geld
zurück
das geld lieber etwas sinnvolleres aus
und zwar werde ich mir dann in zukunft
auch max krank hat es jetzt auch das
blues band microphone von ich habe ihnen
das empfohlen kinder seit monaten was
für mich gut und podcast müssen videos
machen und wahrscheinlich
sittler solle das ist schon das
allerbeste formale raum mit neuen
verhältnissen
der ansatz von teppichen halfinger und
ich habe es wirklich
deswegen glaube ich eher nicht schon
informiert ich brauche jeden möglich los
das mädchen das am bahnhofs aufsehen
sorgen
wir sind jetzt aus dem kinofilm raus und
es war geil gemacht das muss man so
sagen aber es war echt dieser denke den
drei stunden oder so das war viel zu
lernen wir müssen hatten wir zu leise
reden weil die anderen herrschen strafen
und wir liegen jetzt noch zimmer und
extreme das sind es nicht mal zwölf
brauche ich
oder aber zeit es ist 23 650 erwärmung
macht auch stimmen welche nach hause und
wenn ihr das video nicht wahrscheinlich
schon seit fünf tagen wieder zu hause
ich habe nicht so viel gefilmt ich werde
morgen in hamburg
ich bringe ihnen der weg fährt nach
österreich wieder am bahnhof lüneburg
zwölf stunden und ich frage euch gleich
nach hause dann muss endlich mal ein
friseurtermin und ich wollte nur sagen
ich film nichts auf der rückfahrt
wahrscheinlich habe ich eigentlich schon
gesagt aber auch keines mega heiß und
alles mögliche und einfach sonst mit
einer schönen tag heute während 36 grad
hier und das werk